[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
what is popping everybody my name is
Justin Woodward and I'm one of the
co-founders of the mix and black voice
in gaming as well as an advisor on the
black game developer fund welcome to
Black voice and gaming we are going to
talk to some creative and talented black
game developers today it has been a
minute but I am back and helping to host
the black voicing gaming stream with my
amazing co-hosts what's happening guys
what is up thank you Justin it's always
exciting to be here my name is Derek
Fields I am a game designer professor
and advisor for black voices in gaming
it's one of my favorite things to be
able to join the two of you on this show
oh but this time the two of you usually
does me and you right so now yeah Justin
with this which is exciting uh no again
I'm excited to be here with both of
y'all uh always excited to get to chat
with the developers and see the other
people who are contributing to the
industry what about you Des
oh my God okay guys I just want you to
know this is our second time doing it
and the first time Derek did not
introduce me so I'm very proud of you
very much
[Laughter]
um
hey everyone it's
and joined by some of my favorite people
in the gaming space my name is Destiny
and I'm the creator of games for games
I'm also the marketing manager at
Freedom Games and one of the hosts at
level one gaming on the 2xp podcast I'm
super excited to be here if you can't
tell we have an amazing showcase for you
we're bringing in some new developers
some new content creators and uh we
might have some announcements that you
guys would be really excited to hear
about so before we get into any of that
Derek is going to jump in and tell us a
little bit more about bvig why it
started and what it needs
that's right so bvg was created in June
of 2020 during the protests and
demonstrations that United us worldwide
black voices in gaming has gone from a
showcase to a non-profit organization
that helps accelerate the growth of
professional game developers now you
might be wondering how do we do all of
that well our mission is to facilitate a
space where game Studio entrepreneurs
can have access to the funding meet
Publishers and connect with mentors to
help them succeed
now Dustin what about them sponsors
we could not start the show without
giving a shout out to our awesome
partners and sponsors for this showcase
first we'd like to thank our sponsors
for their support PlayStation ID at Xbox
raw Fury if we if it wasn't for them we
wouldn't even have got started Razer
Wilson suncini for being pro bono
partner for the black voice and gaming
cohort and we have a very special
announcement today you heard it here
first we are honored to be partnering
with Netflix on our first accelerator
program called The Experience Excellence
accelerator where we will be helping to
fund four black game development mobile
Studios the accelerator will include
workshops and curriculum from
professional mentors and networking
opportunities with the goal of helping
to boost professional developers
progress on their games and to get them
ready for further investment and
Publishing opportunities if you're
interested in being a part of the
experience Excellence bvig Netflix
mobile game accelerator please submit
your application and go to the website
for more details gonna be dope
absolutely congratulations on that and
thanks so much to Netflix and guys when
you look that up make sure you it's like
XP as an experience not exp just just in
case yeah there's a big old name all
right a whole the whole thing but um
let's let's not forget about our
broadcast Partners twitch gaming IGN
Gamespot and steam they're they're the
reason why you're watching this today
and we we just want to say we really
really appreciate it because um there
are a lot of showcases out there and you
guys chose us so thanks and speaking of
steam don't forget to check out the
mixes event page where you can learn
more about black voices and gaming
titles buy the available games and add
them to your wish list remember wishlist
helps so much it lets steam know that
these games are upcoming they're really
popular and then you know other people
get to see the great games that our
developers are creating now let's talk
about some donations some merch and
socials if you want donate to Black
voices and gamings tiltify here's your
chance grab your phones snap the QR code
on the screen no amount is too small and
we truly appreciate it check out our
merch the bvig shirts we're always
looking to expand just as out here
repping right now gorgeous model thank
you thank you also remember to follow
bvig on Twitter at BVI gaming Black
voices and gaming on YouTube and on
Instagram and now that we've shouted out
our appreciation
it's time to get the show rolling our
first guest is Sir billion that's
billion like in you make a billion
dollars like remember that there's money
on this name it's gold in that with
Breeze in the clouds
[Music]
all right
oh my God that was cute
the uh become a storm in canine Farm
really had me too the little Barks in
the background like you could hear him
barking as he was like doing his moves
but listen the music threw me back to
like Cowboy Bebop style like I was
jamming as it was you know what I mean
like that Jazzy kind of like upbeat like
no that was sick that was very sick oh
yeah oh yeah that's a throw hands Jazz
you know thank you thank you that was
perfect but we're gonna jump right into
the interview with the amazing developer
behind this game sir billion what is up
are you with us come on through
I am here what's up
hey like the shirt
well marked
now it's a pleasure to meet you thank
you for taking some time out I know it's
like very very busy right now summer
games fast and and you're developing a
game but uh could you tell us a little
bit about yourself kind of like what got
you started and the inspiration behind
you know puppies kicking butt
puppies kicking butt I love that yeah so
um
breezes um
probably my first project of this scale
it kind of started off as a um really
like a opportunity to learn how to get
into game development
um kind of fresh out of college I've
done a lot of like game jams and smaller
games before just to kind of test the
waters of what it's like and then one
day I I was uh actually daydreaming on a
um a bus ride home and this random idea
came up where it was just like hey what
if like this small dog is stuck trying
to fix the weather on this broken cloud
or something like that right
um and then eventually kind of expanded
into you know what it is now this large
uh 2D hand-drawn game where you're
quirky you know beating stuff up in the
clouds
I love corgis okay is there a reason why
you picked a corgi in particular or is
it just because they're cute and they
have big booties like
they have big ears too but yeah no I I
thought it would be cute to find like a
a cool but small dog
um to kind of feature as the protagonist
and um we actually had a bit of trouble
starting off because we weren't sure if
he was going to be on twos or fours and
um I was a little bit of a mediocre a
mediocre artist back then and so he was
coming out looking like a fox for a very
long time
um So eventually once I got a few
artists on board we've got the um we got
pretty used to look more like a corgi so
he's super cute like I love him yeah I'm
a big fan
and we've just jumped into the game so
like Derek Derek's got the ones and twos
on this I'm super excited because you
guys know what it's like when I play a
video game but um
can you tell us a little bit about like
the design like so you talked about the
Corgi and like why you wanted to get a
cute little dog which he definitely
looks like a main character like you
guys did incredible on that but like
when it comes to lives
yeah when it comes to the style of game
did you always know it was going to be a
bit of like a fighter side scroller kind
of like platforming type is that what
you wanted to go for
so originally when we started it out it
was um it was actually a 3D platformer
at first I kind of just had like the
generic
um 3D platformer stuff where it was just
jumping on stuff collecting coins and we
added in the brawling just to kind of
give
um Breeze some type of combat aspect but
it wasn't really mature back then
um then eventually I started really
thinking about uh what a lot of my
references are based off of and it was
stuff like Sonic the Hedgehog and Crash
Bandicoot a little bit of Mega Man
um and a lot of like Saturday morning
cartoons and so I think it was around
2015.
um I sat down and said hey why don't we
just make freeze like a 2d cartoon kind
of game uh so from there we started
really trying to develop uh Breeze a lot
of the other characters so feel more
like Saturday morning cartoon characters
um okay you know so inspiration from
like Sonic and Crash Bandicoot and stuff
like that just having all the characters
look really appealing in exists in this
uh cartoon-like world
yeah no it totally works I'm getting
like Chip and Dale I'm getting DuckTales
I'm getting this is like a show that you
would watch on Disney with a big bowl of
cereal
[Music]
um
yeah like it could you could see this
turning into a series you should think
about that definitely because I think it
would work it's so so so so so cute
um so I'm gonna throw it to Derek
because he's in here and he's like
throwing some Combos and like giving
them what for Derek how's the game uh
the gameplay feel
you know my favorite part about playing
this right now is that the combat feels
Snappy and responsive to every bit of
input that I'm you know throwing at the
main character right now and so I think
my my first question was you know what
was it like with you and your team uh
just balancing out the feel of this game
uh definitely was a chore
um so since Bree's kind of mixes in uh
several different genres we've got like
the platforming aspects we've got some
inputs that are very similar to games
like Smash Brothers uh but then we also
drew a lot of inspiration from fighting
games like um I always like to say
Marvel versus Capcom 2
um and a lot of the faster anime
Fighters so finding a way to you know
make all of that work being able to um
feel like you could do cool flashy fast
stuff
um it took a while to really kind of
like nail that out
um
even with like getting on the enemy
characters as well as The Boss
characters developed there was a lot of
back and forth between you know hey this
guy is strong and this guy is weak so we
did a lot of like right you know
internal play testing to get the AI to
feel like it's um
you know uh challenging uh to a certain
degree but not too challenging to her
like uh we're not calling it puppy Souls
yeah yeah within our team like we had it
at a point where uh like everyone but me
was struggling so
puppy Souls it was called
I see I see
I can tell that like he's on a train
that's not in the U.S because like dude
is just minding his own business like
he's sleeping
you know I mean if it was in the U.S
people would have already had other
cameras World Stars
[Laughter]
the character's so iconic though like I
really feel like I don't know how to
explain this but he seems like a
franchise starter do you know what I
mean like you have Mario who's a
Francesca Sonic who's a and so like was
there a lot of thought put into that or
was it just kind of like I just want a
really cute character who's gonna kick
butt or were you thinking about future
plans with them
it was kind of a like a future thought
of like let's make Breeze look you know
very iconic the way that you know when
Mario and Sonic came out you know their
designs really uh shine so
um yeah pretty deliberate on that front
we just wanted to make him seem like a
really strong character that could stand
out
I mean he does he really does now
game
tell me please tell me that you have a
steam page up we do we actually launched
a steam page I think about two weeks ago
excellent
and guys make sure you wishlist this
game because it's incredible and
wishlist helped the developer so much it
like helps with their algorithm it shows
steam that this game is up and coming
and popular and honestly I think it's
going to be absolutely incredible like
just I want to play it but Dara gets to
play it this time it feels it feels as
good as it looks that's what I'm telling
y'all
yeah I'd be jealous too if I if I didn't
have the controller in hand see see
I'm Joe it's not
that I could tell I could probably do
some damage just smashes some buttons
bags
because I'm so terrible at remembering
Combos and on that do you have to
remember any kind of like complicated
combos to like really get far in the
game or can a button Smasher like me
like still enjoy it yeah so we have one
button that's literally just attack and
then we've got another button that is uh
like a special attack so I it's it's
interesting I I got into a lot of
fighting games while developing Breeze
uh because I always enjoy like watching
tournaments and stuff and I was always
really bad at you know inputting quarter
circles and stuff like that
um
definitely have to learn to kind of
understand it but I wanted to simplify
that for Breeze and that like there are
you know a couple of like Advanced
things that you could do but it doesn't
require like a um you know a crazy
amount of uh combo input sequences that
you have to remember so I appreciate
that so much
like I really do
is there a demo up for the game right
now
uh there's not a demo up for the game
right now uh I have been going to a few
cons as of late uh with this feel in
particular to give you know folks an
opportunity to kind of get a good gauge
of like how the gameplay feels
nice nice do you do you kind of have a
date when you might have a demo because
I definitely want people to try this
game out like it just looks too good to
be true I mean if you can't tell us that
information it's okay you know you can
tell me after the show
unfortunately okay
guys at some point there will be like a
demo I'm sure I'm sure
I'm sure yeah just like this is so good
I like what you play we have to throw we
have to throw attention to the to the
comic book panels you know it looks so
great the art style is just consistent
through from gameplay to cut scenes I'm
I'm I'm already hooked
I'm gonna try and beat this whole game I
you better have enough levels here today
because I'm just gonna
until there's nothing play after Derek
plays
now before we jump to the end to get
your socials so everybody can follow you
I know that you've worked with Humble
Bundle and you've had some work with the
black game developer fund can you tell
us a little bit how that got started how
you got in contact with people we're I
want to know I want to know all the
details
okay yeah so funny enough um Justin hit
me up on Twitter um many summers ago to
kind of you know inform me about the
black game developer fun uh then from
there we moved on to actually building
out a prototype um weeds and those funds
that we showed up to Humble
um they loved it so much they ended up
signing with us
sure now
to people and and that's I mean like
that's what you do like that's that's
what black voices and gaming is all
about is setting people up to succeed
and so you're another success story so
it's great having you on and talking
about how all of that came together now
if people want to find out more about
you keep up to date with the game and
what you're doing can you drop your
socials for us
for sure yeah we've got our main website
breezethegame.com uh we also have a
Twitter account that one's at Breeze
game uh that's where I do a lot of our
my announcements and I probably meme too
much on Twitter but if you enjoy that
kind of stuff you'll get it from you
can't name them too much there's no
that's what it is sometimes
he was like we have the games coming out
it's April 1st everybody get excited
did you do that
that was terrible I made like
um three or four uh
different versions of the game if you
will
might have been a little bit too
believable
um
like the Sonic got murdered game that
was crazy
which is a functioning game like it is
completely functioning yeah yeah but
thanks again for coming on
um we really I didn't mean to cut y'all
off I was just like
but thank you again for coming out we
really appreciate it
and that's it guys like I hope you check
out the game make sure you go to steam
make sure you wish listen it really
really helps with the algorithm it lets
steam know that this game is popping
it's up and coming and that way it shows
up on more people's wish lists and all
kinds of things like that so go do that
and again huge thank you to Sir billion
for taking some time out to come into
the show your game is great it's iconic
and I cannot wait to steal Derek's
stroller so I can play this
you gotta pry it from these hands
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you just saw heart machines hyper light
breaker I am every bit of excited that
this game is coming out but this doesn't
match my excitement to talk to our
guests that we have today as Danielle
Wallace from Hyperlite art from heart
machines so Danielle how you doing
I'm good doing great how are you guys
good good I am super hyped I was trying
to I was trying to hold my composure
after he was like everything is just so
hype with the build up and then the
after credits I don't know if you call
it the after credit scene it's it's
looking super sick
I was like jamming out again when it
played I was like yeah
the game for sure
how can you not it's it's hard not to
Just Vibe with the whole trailer I mean
the music everything is is coming
through
it's it's so gorgeous it's been such a
fantastic project to work on
um especially the style like I feel like
I was such a good uh fit to be a part of
it and I feel wanted to work on it yeah
and and that's what brings us to to our
conversation today Danielle I understand
that you are a 3D environment Artist At
Heart machine games can you tell us a
little bit about you know what it's like
working at the studio and working on
such a cool project
um yeah so I'm a 3D environment I'm just
there I do uh just for a committee intro
I do a little bit of everything
um so not just organic but also hard
surface and a bunch of other stuff like
across the whole thing so I can just
point through when Trey was playing I
did that and I did that uh I kind of
deal
um but uh it's been absolutely fantastic
uh being at heart machines the team is
um literally everyone gets along so well
uh and every day I go into work uh
because we're hybrid right now so we go
in three days a week it's like Monday
was a Friday
um uh everyone's like so nice welcoming
um like even when I first got there I'd
like hey you want to do this on the
weekend hey we're going here hey we're
doing this and it was it was so
refreshing because you hear about so
many horror stories in the industry and
I feel like I genuinely got lucky for
this being like my first big uh intro
into the industry getting uh being at
this company if I'm being honest yeah
where's the location where where's the
uh heart machine located where are you
located
is in Culver City and that's where I
live as well so I have maybe like a 10
minute commute if that's uh something is
which is fantastic as well
that's that's super dope just real quick
how did you get started at the studio
like kind of where where did you get
started and how did you get to uh heart
machine games I've been familiar and I
know Alex we've had uh we had hyper
light Drifter at a at a few events so
it's awesome to see that you're a part
of the team
yeah um um so I was at
um from I actually kind of like got
lucky again I ran out of college I was
working at this small studio called Sky
Farm which did a little bit of
children's animation as well as games so
that was my contract work and then after
that I was at numinous games which made
that Dragon cancer the VR game
um and you worked yeah I didn't work on
that one but I worked on with their
upcoming project oh okay okay cool
um
and so it felt almost ironic and like to
then go from bad to Heart machine
because uh it's another impactful game
right like we know how absolutely
impactful that Dragon cancer was and to
be able to go to another company that's
like hey a focus on emotion telling a
good story
um and just kind of like making a
difference similar to like storytelling
or what they're trying to convey uh and
themes Etc which is feels really great
open heart machine now for
oh it's been two years two years and
some change oh really wow that's cool it
doesn't feel like it
it's because you're too busy making all
these dope assets
yeah
speaking of you mentioned you mentioned
earlier well first first before I asked
this next question twice now you said
that you got lucky and I don't think
it's yeah it's not luck you are a
talented 3D artist and you deserve to be
in the position at your end so say you
you manifested it everything happened
exactly as it should like luck had
nothing to do with it
um you mentioned earlier being excited
about some of the assets that are
included in in the game and being and
being like Oh you know I saw that and or
or I got to do that and I've I've been a
very personal witness to some of these
Twitter moments of you identifying some
of the contributions in those trailers
um is there anything in this trailer
that we just saw that you were
responsible for that we can call out
oh
um actually yeah
um wildly one of the biggest things in
the game is uh the background City so
when you start the game you literally
have the entirety of the like City
skyline of like everything behind you
and that was like 85 me if not a little
bit more
um and throw a little bit of the
background on that
um it wasn't like they were like hey
this is your task which would have been
wild anyway uh I ended up doing just a
couple of apartments and I did another
apartment another apartment then all of
the
um is it water towers and then they were
like oh also the bridge and then after a
point I was like okay even my lead was
like this is just your piece now like
this is this is yours even down to some
of the lighting in that area when it
turns to nighttime and then like shifts
to nighttime City Lights uh and stuff oh
so that's one thing another oh sorry you
can go ahead oh no no no go ahead go
ahead I don't want to interrupt you I'm
getting excited I'm like thinking of
things
thank you
um to I think I'll say two more big ones
was one of them uh when you run across
there's like a mural which is really
unique
um I wish we had more things like that
in the game probably maybe even down the
line um but there's a mural you walk
past it's like a almost like a Pixar
skeleton that's on the side of one of
the buildings that you see real quick
then you go past and I actually did the
each individual I placed each individual
tile on that thing because I wanted it
to read like it was like pixel art which
seems kind of like a homage right to
drip shirt
um but yeah I felt like I felt on to do
that one as well if I'm being honest and
another big one is the uh Titan swords
no matter like where you are in the game
you can always see one because they are
like bigger than skyscrapers if I'm
being honest because they are no matter
where you are you could see like the
huge uh like the lore of Titan swords
being like left there and from the
Titans there so that was also an honor
to work on because that's also one of
the bigger pieces in uh Drifter as well
yeah
yeah it feels like I mean this is
definitely the case you know because as
I develop games I know Derek you develop
games the environment is a character for
sure the biggest character so you having
a hand in that is pretty pretty awesome
it's it's also cool to see like the
different camera angle changes and that
type of thing can you kind of break down
a synopsis of how the environment uh
activates the player the player
activates the the environment and how it
plays a role in the gameplay
um yeah yeah so
say oh that's a hard one how I request
that one
um
the style plays such a huge role in the
overall feel of the game when we were
every time we make an asset it's like
hey does this feel like it's in Universe
hey does this feel like drifter uh even
my lead gets like so excited like being
able to like make uh like Tech blocks or
oh the mods to like the drop down labs
and Drifter right like you'd fall and go
underneath the long thing uh and then
like hey what does that look like in 3D
or like hey what would this asset look
like in 3D and be able to stay on style
and actually legitimately get up give
pieces of ourselves for how we think
that would look as well because
sometimes we don't get like full full
Concepts usually most of the time it is
but if
um actually on that point playing into
the environment thing
um it's been fantastic being able to
have so much creative Direction at heart
machine as well like it's not always
just like hey here's a thing if I'm like
oh hey I think this would look a little
better this way or hey uh her in
universe I think this color change or uh
even like some
um when I was making a Boss Arena I got
to do like like little changes big
changes here and there in regard to how
that was approached so it feels
um wild to be given creative directs
especially since I've only been in
Industry like three years now so like
you guys are trust me with that but but
it feels really good
there you go yeah
that's incredible it you know I I'm I'm
curious to know is there any other Media
or games uh that have played an
influence to you know some of the
content that you're driving in uh inside
heart machine
hmm
if I I had an answer before you said
like the second half of that and then I
was like then there's like another
answer
um for games in general that have
influence me and I think influenced my
art style
um I loved the Spyro series growing up
um as well as like Cooper Harvest Moon
Etc and how how well the environments
told a story and told what the universe
was right you can throw art together but
if you aren't telling it through a
certain style or angle then you don't
get the full breath of like hey what is
this world what are you supposed to feel
what are the emotions you're supposed to
feel through the game
um I think in regard to specifically uh
harm machine we've taken like a couple
of influences from one of them when I
think that was most influential for me
was rhyme at least in regard to like the
art style I love how I love how
absolutely soft and open that world
feels and warm like I think for most of
the game there's like not even like
music playing it's like you just feel
like you're in a different universe and
like that's what I want the player to
feel when they're going through our
machines I think so they're going
through your hyperlane breaker
okay
that's Hilary yeah that's that's super
cool what are you playing now
like just in general like
it's always cool to see what folks like
developers and artists are playing you
know while they're making stuff
okay the default answer is like tears
are the kings of uh but
uh I'm playing through that right now
because it's Goss that game's gorgeous
um but another one is uh
Horizon preventive blast is another one
because I I haven't got I've really
gotten through that game because of how
gorgeous the environments are like I
just start and I'm like whoa look at
that how that's placed or like look at
the details on that and I'm like I don't
know what they did
um can you see more talks on that I
think one more is Disco Elysium that's
another big one for me as well I love to
have the absolutely great storytelling
in that game wait which one oh disco
okay yeah
that's cool yeah I like that one a lot
I still need to LEAP into that one but
uh Danielle I think this is all the time
that we have with you today uh it's been
excellent to hear both your vision and
your contributions to Heart machine and
I'm excited to see these giant swords
and other assets you've developed for
hyper light breaker
um before we're out of here where can
people find you if they want to keep up
with all the tweets of you identifying
the assets that you worked on
yeah so you can find me
um I think on several I think I'm the
same name of several on Twitter D Panda
heart so D Panda heart
um uh twitter.com uh same thing for
Instagram as well as
um I'm not sure how to like link my
LinkedIn but I'm on there too if you
search for me
I'll pop up for sure on there because
there's not many Danielle's I think
Daniel Wallace is on in the game to
space
well thanks for joining us I mean it's
so awesome that you're enthusiastic
about it been in the game for now three
years is that what you said yeah that's
right that's awesome because you're you
know it's not always easy to break in
and you're breaking in at a great place
like you know and you have such creative
freedom and and great collaborative
experiences so thanks for joining us it
was good thank you so much for having me
all right
[Music]
that is roller girl it looks super dope
and we are here with Indigo Doyle what
is up indigo hey
um not much thank you for having me I'm
excited to be here and talk about the
game
yeah thanks for joining it
uh no fire away it's all you
okay yeah so yeah thanks for joining us
um the game looks really interesting
I've never seen anything like it really
uh it looks very Serene and like an
interesting narrative experience can you
tell us a little bit about roller girl
yeah for sure thank you I'm glad that
it's coming across as that because
that's what I really want people to see
um so yeah it's very much a relaxing
game of taking your time not having a
ton of time constraints or things that
you have to complete
um I kind of always say that it's like a
game of side quests because whenever I
play a long game I I don't even do the
main quest half the time right
um so I really enjoy that and it's also
heavily based on my childhood growing up
in a small City where I would
rollerblade like everywhere
um so it's really exciting to sort of
put myself into a game and see my
experiences come to life and watch other
people sort of play them and relate to
them as well which is it's been really
awesome
how did you get started in game
development and get started with this
particular game
um so I got started in game development
um when I went to school back in 2013.
um I didn't really have any idea what I
wanted to do other than I liked drawing
so it was like maybe concept art
um but then once I started doing concept
art I realized that I didn't like it and
I started learning 3D for the first time
and I was like immediately obsessed
um and so from there I started
practicing building up a portfolio and
after several years of kind of doing it
on the side and working
um in a different field I finally
decided to just take the plunge uh
during the pandemic actually and go out
into doing freelance full-time and then
from there I kind of started thinking
about what kind of games I would like to
make myself and I was like people say
write what you know so I feel like
develop what you know kind of works a
little bit too
um and I just wanted to make kind of
just a little proof of concept for this
game and then it kind of just grew from
there and people really like the idea of
the the whole premise and everything and
especially the the way that the music
affects the game so it's just been a
really exciting Journey from there
it looks it looks super cool Derek is
driving right now can you talk a little
bit about what's going on with the game
and The Narrative of the story
yeah for sure
um So within the game the um the main
character is Naomi she's based off of me
um and so she's mainly rollerblading
around this small little town
um everyone around is kind of like a
quirky local small town person with
entertaining personalities and like
quirky little stories
um and so she has recently been
um gifted this car that has a bit of
work that needs to be done to it so she
can't drive it so she's rollerblading
around asking people hey do you have any
jobs I can do so I can make some money
um and fix up this car which uh I came
up with the idea because that actually
kind of happened to me a little bit
um I purchased my first car I was so
excited I saved up so much money and it
was like a nice like kind of sports car
not really what car was it
um okay so it's not a sports car because
now that you've asked it's gonna be
embarrassing because it's actually a
sports car
compared to what
compared to what other people were
buying at my age I was like this is like
a sporty car it was like a Tiburon like
a Hyundai Tiburon from like 2004. um so
it was like kind of curvy compared
everyone was buying like a Pontiac
Sunfire and I was like I'm gonna be
different and I'm gonna get this blue
Tiburon
um so yeah I bought that and it had a
crack in the windshield it was missing
spark plugs I couldn't drive it uh and
everyone was mocking me they were like
you have a car but you can't drive it
like haha
um and I was like just like sad for like
six to eight months trying to save up
money to fix it so uh I really liked
putting that idea into the game of like
you have this but you can't use it
um and I also I still loved
rollerblading around when I had the car
so it's kind of just combining two of
those things
did you really do I'm just curious did
you do odd jobs to get the money or was
it
not not really
um not specifically odd jobs I did have
a paper route for six years so that's
where this Quest that you're doing right
now kind of comes into play
um and there was a lot of like if you
had a paper route and you had to take
the weekend off you had to find someone
to cover for you uh which is basically
what the character just did he was like
I want to go somewhere do my papers for
me and you're like well I could use the
money
um so why not but yeah I actually had
like a part-time job at the movie
theater so I didn't do odd jobs but
um I probably would have if needed
tell can you tell us a little bit about
the the playlist system because it's
very unique I mean just looking at like
checking out the trailer you go into
that can you talk about that system and
where you're going with it
yeah for sure um so the playlist system
is like literally just based off of when
I was like 15 and I had an iPod Nano and
I had playlists on it that were based
off of sort of how I was feeling so if I
was having a really great day I'd have
this like really great playlist where it
felt like everything was just like
gorgeous and sunny and bright
um and then if I was having a bad day
I'd have sort of the opposite where it's
very like Moody and like sad
um and I feel like as a teenager
everything is kind of like really
dramatic so if you're having a bad day
and you're listening to that song the
world around you kind of feels like oh
like everything is like shrinking in on
me and I'm like Alone
um and if you're having a great day then
it's kind of like sun is shining you're
walking on sunshine type of thing
um so that's what we're implementing
here of having the music not only change
the visuals but also affect the
narrative and what things are available
to you depending on that state as well
so can you like collect other like songs
like boost up your playlists I'm super
curious about this
yes so we actually can
um there is us a couple of pickups
placed around the world that you can uh
you can grab and they'll unlock new
music for your playlist
um nice which is pretty I'm pretty happy
about that because it's kind of based
off of when you're kind of like walking
around I always say like after it snows
you find like little stuff on the ground
that people dropped into snow Banks I
couldn't find any more
um so it's kind of based off of that if
you find an item the song that's linked
to it is kind of related to that item
and tells a bit of a story about like
who dropped it or what that item meant
to that person
that's cool who like who's doing the the
music are you sourcing it from different
artists that you like are you doing the
music
right so I'm glad you asked that because
I was actually about to to point it out
um so right now the music is um just
some free music that we found but we're
in the progress of contacting
um Indie bands from Ontario that kind of
give off the same Vibe of the game so we
can license them into it
um and sort of shine like a bit of a
light on the local music industry here
which is really exciting um I like to
always say that Avril Lavigne was from
the town that this is based off of so
like she should be in it but um yeah
we're planning on getting some uh some
local artists into the game for sure
speaking of the town uh you know as I'm
cruising around here I'm delivering
newspapers and there's definitely a
sense of life and reality to the
neighborhood
um you know I'd love to know more about
what it was like uh you know building
the environment and building a space
that uh you know feels authentic for
sure
um so yeah it was based off of
Belleville Ontario which if anyone knows
like shout out to you because no one
knows where it is because it's so small
but
um I grew up there and it was really
exciting to kind of like spend time
building it um people think that I'm
kind of insane because I had pretty much
hand built all of these houses but I was
like really dedicated to make them look
unique
um so like majority of the houses should
look different like I'll tell you a
secret there they are a lot of the same
house but they do have like aspects that
are different
um different materials different props
outside but the bases are are pretty
much the same but there are a couple of
houses that are like very specifically
built to look exactly the same as the
house in real life because I got really
obsessed
um because uh yeah making making profs
and environments is my like main focus
so I really had a good time
um making all of these assets and it's
been really in just interesting to sort
of like see the town
sort of like become itself and then
watching other people go through it
um they don't really have the same sort
of like memories of the area as me so
it's it's interesting to see what they
interpret it as um because to me I'm
like yeah that's that's Albert Street
that's totally chill and they're like I
don't know where I am and I'm like oh I
guess not everyone not everyone grew up
there like
this dude is trying to like climb trees
with rollerblades I'm Amazed
I will do whatever it takes to deliver
these papers let me show you oh my gosh
we actually have a bit of a glitch where
if you jump on certain things near trees
you could kind of glitch the collision
and jump into the tree but
um I will I will leave that to the
imagination if you want to try it you
can
how many people are on your team
um so right now I'm just trying to I
keep losing chalk because in my head
it's like five but I think it's yeah so
we're four right now sorry
um there's a lot of moving people but
yeah there's four of us right now
that's awesome where are you at in
development
um so right now we're kind of in concept
definition phase
um we've done a lot of pre-production
and uh proof of concept testing stuff
like that and now we're trying to sort
of build out the like all of the main
mechanics which they are in place but
they just we want to polish them a bit
more and allow them to feel just a bit
more intuitive
um and then we're also in the phase of
looking for more funding hopefully
finding a compatible publisher and uh
just fully building it out we're hoping
to finish development within about a
year but it's um it's very dependent on
a lot of moving pieces
yeah
go ahead Garrett
uh no you know just tacking on a a sort
of a wrapping question here but
um you know building this sort of Slice
of Life game was there anything that you
wanted to include but you were like ah
you know this one's not going to make it
into the project maybe next one
um there's a lot of like little features
like I have feature creep every day
where I really want to add in like
putting in tricks or putting in a
customization system
um having unlockable areas kind of like
Tony Hawk
um yeah yeah yeah like a lot of there's
a lot of little things so it's it's kind
of hard to not put them in
um just because of budget and timing
um I always said that like if the budget
was endless we would never finish this
game because it was so many things I
want to add into it
um but yeah I'm happy with how it's
going though sorry
can you sketch
um no we decided not to put uh cars in
the game just because
the vibe is very like relaxed and even
in the city that it's from uh there's
not that much traffic like you could lay
in the middle of the road and probably
not get hit for like at least 20 minutes
like it's working for skating yes
exactly
yeah the game looks super dope
um thank you thanks for sharing it with
us uh where can we find I know the demo
is on itch right do you have a steam
page setup and everything oh so right
now we don't have a steam page but we
will hopefully be announcing a steam
page in the next month or so
okay you got to get that mug up so we
can promote your steam page to get you
some wish with ASAP for sure for sure
for sure so where can we find more about
you the development of roller girl and
everything that you're working on
this is at roller girl game on Twitter
I also have an Instagram and a Discord
which is all linked on the Twitter bio
um and we also have a newsletter that we
send out every month so people can join
that as well
um and yeah we're pretty much everywhere
on socials as roller girl game
yeah and then I guess for me personally
it's it's my name Indigo Doyle on
Twitter um that's my main my main source
of of social media for the moment
sure well thank you so much for joining
us everybody check out roller girl get
the demo uh and we gotta talk about some
funding opportunities potentially I know
I'm putting now I'm putting you on blast
again but yeah I gotta connect on that
for sure I'll take it
yeah for sure thank you so much
awesome thank you great thank you
all right well we have another special
guest with us today that is Lizette
Detroit Montgomery Lisette how are you
doing
how are you doing
I am doing excellent I'm really excited
to hear about all the things you're up
to some of the uh some of the stirrings
that are happening uh you know of course
those details we'll dig into very
shortly but if you just give a little
bit a little bit of background about
yourself again and uh you know what what
you're up to these days
hi welcome everyone to the stream
um my name is Lisa tea tree Montgomery
and
um I've been making games for gosh it's
been 22 years now
um I've done everything from Mobile to
PC to a lot of time in AAA so and my
last project was second last two and now
I'm currently starting my own studio
called Cornerstone interactive uh
working on really focused mature
narrative driven games
I'm excited
for being in the industry for it for
this long because I know like you have
to pay your dues or whatever and
sometimes it can be very toxic but like
you stuck with it and it's it's
incredible to see that you've you've
worked on other people's dreams and now
you have your studio and you're working
on what you want to work on and putting
out so like congratulations on that I'm
when I get older I want to be just like
you
thank you
I'm not that old but yes
it's not saying that you're older it's
just saying that like I want to be at
that level that you're at that's what I
am well thank you thank you
just giving you a hard time right out
the gate man so yes
um it's it's been quite the road it's
been quite the ride
yeah yeah it's it's it's true you know
you you've um you've been doing great
things and are continuing to do great
things in the industry
um you know I I think a highlight of
wanting to talk to you today it
certainly centers around uh you know
what's cooking uh you know with
Cornerstone interactive uh but before we
get there would be really excellent to
hear you know about some of that history
uh you mentioned uh Psychonauts and uh
and some other spaces that you've been
involved in as well could you expand on
some of that
yes
um like it's been a long journey in the
last 10 years I've been really focused
on advocacy work
um I think throughout my career
especially coming up I noticed that I
was often the one of two on the floor
you know and everyone knew who I was but
I didn't know who everyone else was
because of that and so for me I sort of
really turned into like what can I do
how can I share my knowledge to change
that and so for the last 10 years I've
been
um working on gameheads which is a
non-profit here in Oakland where we take
students from 18 to 24 and we teach them
how to make video games from their you
know first video game to how many other
prototypes they want to develop with us
we've had some students in the program
for the last total of nine years
and they stayed through us through
college now they're developing
prototypes some of them are getting
published and some of our students are
actually getting hired at some of the
biggest studios in the world
so I'm really proud of the work we're
doing
and I see Cornerstone as the next
extension of that
uh that's incredible
that is really really cool so my
question is like I love that you're
doing advocacy and that you're helping
like younger people come up into like
this industry because we are trying to
build a foundation that is what black
voices and gaming is about what is
some advice that you would give to I'm
gonna take it from like a feminine point
of view because I I'm also in the game
industry and like you said there's only
like there's only so many of us right
what would you give
what kind of advice would you give to a
young black girl who is excited about
gaming gloves gaming but like just
doesn't feel like she fits like what
kind of motivational thing would you say
to her
I would say don't focus on what you see
focus on what you can create
um I think there's a huge opportunity to
create content for when I say a mature
audience I mean emotionally mature
audience not just in you know x-rated
and violy but you know violent Adventure
audience and I think there's a major
distinction there and I think that comes
with creating content specifically for
new demographics we've been hyper
focused on what I would consider a niche
if you look at the total global
population of who gamers are
um and there hasn't been a lot of effort
and really appealing to one older Gamers
more Gamers of color uh more or players
who are not necessarily in interested in
like adversarial sort of games but
collaborative games and so I would say
focus on what you want to play and the
games you want to make instead of
regurgitating the same stuff we've made
because that's not going to get anyone
anywhere I mean there are people who own
that space you're better off like
Reinventing and finding and creating
through your uncles
I love that that sound advice so if
you're listening out there that this
goes for anyone actually who's listening
today and who wants to get into the
gaming field like create
I think it's best when you tell stories
that you know and then you're able to
form them and mold them into something
that like
it's just something beautiful about
storytelling so do what you know and if
you do what you know I guarantee you'll
find somebody who will pick up on it and
love it and I feel like that's basically
what you're saying so thank you for that
yeah yeah that that resonates in a
really big way
um I you know a part of the the work
that you've been doing in game heads and
the the value that's been uh creating
there you're identifying you know the
folks who have been uh going on and uh
creating prototypes and so on uh you
know how are any of these people uh you
know starting to find their way as
potential contributors to Cornerstone or
uh do you find yourself uh you know
seeking to continue to collaborate with
any of those individuals that you've
mentored or supported
I think for me Cornerstone is sort of
what we consider like the the next phase
and so it is a separate entity for me
from gameheads that is purely focused on
people who are 18 to 24.
um but Cornerstone is a business so we
are going to be a premier gaming studio
so we'll be hiring people from game
heads hopefully but in the short term
what we're going to be looking for is
more senior talent to help build the
structure of the studio before we start
bringing in people who are new but the
whole goal is that the whole Arc of the
company as we develop you know more and
more hits so we can induce of like
hackathon or sort of game Jam culture
within the studio as well so that anyone
can can bring a pitch forward so that's
the long-term goals we're creating a
safe fun like creative play Space
um for people who haven't been catered
to before and I want to see what kind of
stories and opportunities come from
creating that space I'm really excited
about that
yeah yeah that's wonderful I I have I
have one other follow-up question
relating to you know kind of making
these Transitions and and developing a
new space
um as somebody who too is in a state of
uh developing a new studio or sorry
expanding uh some developments at a
studio for those developers out there
those people who are interested in some
of the more entrepreneurial side of
games uh any advice that you might give
to somebody who is breaking out a little
differently uh you know maybe not
seeking to work for their favorite
company or work for a new company but
saying I want to make something of my
own
I would say the best thing you could do
is get to a MVP as quickly as possible
um it's a lot of people just sit in the
ideation phase and they think about all
the aspects of the game and the every
little Nuance but there's like nothing
on the controller to play so you're
really kind of you could be really stuck
in this thought space but the proof is
in the pudding and that pudding is what
happens on the screen so the quickly
quicker you can get to a minimal viable
product and have something to play the
quicker you can build pipelines to
iterate so that you can get to good
faster the better off you'll be and like
don't get stuck so much in the
conceptual phase that you're just kind
of lost in the world you're built for
yourself and you can't get out
yeah yeah that's excellent advice
like a lot of people
start making games
change
story like you might have a core idea
but there are so many changes that are
going to happen like get that light
outline and then just start working just
start doing it that's what I've been
hearing from a lot of developers and a
lot of people at Studios like just do it
just make it happen
um and I know that that's not that's
easier said than done but we have
lizette's here she did it
Derek's here he's he he did it you know
what I mean everybody who's been here
has at some point had to start with an
idea you know and it's blossomed into
something incredible
um I had a question so I know you were
talking about the age range from 18 to
24 is there any specific reason why
you've picked that age range and it
doesn't move on you know any older or
any younger like what is it about that
age range that you were like these are
the ones that these are the the the kids
and and the adults that I want to focus
on
um a bit of a correction it's well it's
14 to 24 but a lot of our students oh
okay okay
well I think to one of two things
um especially the high school student
range we sort of Target that race
because it's kind of a last hurdle to
get students into stem before they get
into college so ideally we'd like to get
them exposed to these Concepts as
quickly as possible get them make it at
first game as quickly as possible
because the longer they're exposed to
these Concepts the more knowledge they
will gain over time and so that gives
them a wake up on someone who's just
starting right in college
um plus
um it gives them something to show when
they're applying to schools so they
could say oh I made a prototype I'm
serious about this rather than saying I
think this would be a great idea but not
really having a strong understanding
um so for us it's trying to capture them
while they are captive audience
um
I think most teenagers play games now
especially since the pandemic since it
was really their only social outlet that
was accessible to them so what you're
really seeing now is a New Generation
generation Alpha is completely online
like 100 almost played games unless your
parents don't let them and they're still
being indoctrinated into these toxic
cultures right yeah so what we want is
for our students to really think about
themselves as game creators not just
consumers and what kind of games that
they want to create for themselves not
the reflection of what has been given to
them
I love that and okay I we're running
close on like the end of time but
I know it's in Oakland but do you guys
have any plans of expanding to other
areas or is this just like I really
wanted to focus on where I live and help
my community
um the program is actually online it's
free it's all year round and anyone
from any time zone that can make it work
is allowed to join we have you know we
have students in Hawaii we have students
that are out of the country we have
students that are in the east coast so
we expanded the program to make sure
that we can get as many you know
students that as we can access if they
really want it
um and with Cornerstone we're doing the
same thing we're going to be a remote
Studio because I want to hire artists
from anywhere in the world
um
um I want to you know you can't really
say you're a diverse company if you're
only willing to hire within the United
States so for me I think it's important
that that international access
um in the digital divide sort of removes
that barrier
I love that thank you for sharing that
with us you've been I've learned so much
and I feel like there's so much more I
could learn but we have such a short
amount of time but if you are interested
and you want to find out more definitely
look into this Lizette if they want to
learn how to become a part of the
program if they want to see what you're
doing and how the studio is going and
maybe you know apply where can they get
all that information out
sure if you're a student or someone who
is actually in college but looking for
people to make games with and learning
looking to learn from the best in the
industry you can go to
gameheadsoakland.org when our
application process opens usually in the
fall make sure you apply because those
slots get filled quick
um and for Cornerstone interactive I
would say look out in the next few
months we're starting to recruit artists
as we're developing pitches and I'm
hoping to start getting out there to get
some cash flow toward the end of the
year so follow me on Twitter at 16 or on
LinkedIn let me just use my name and uh
keep a lookout there's some exciting
days coming
awesome thank you so much yeah Derek
that was incredible like I feel so
inspired now and I can't hear you if
you're talking Derek are you talking
I I am talking I made the mistake of
getting myself for any background sounds
I have a little one you never know what
to expect I don't understand yes no I I
am excited as well and I was saying you
you heard it here first and so uh yes
please stay tapped in with what Lisette
is up to uh and it's been a pleasure to
be able to hear from your expertise and
um and really gain so much Insight in
such a concise moment
absolutely guys we still have so much
more to go like this is the
you already heard her we have the best
of the best on the show like this is
dope
so again thank you Lizette guys keep up
with her if you're interested if you're
interested in becoming a gamer if you
want to see what else she's putting out
go follow her don't delay literally just
pick up your phone and do it it's so
simple
and uh we'll catch you in the next
interview thanks
hey everybody welcome back I'm super
excited because we have something a
little different this time like I know
we always talk about games and
developers which is definitely dope but
we are going to bring on two creators as
a blurred box I know you guys have heard
of subscription boxes before but this
one is incredible and I I would go into
detail about it but I'm going to let
them explain how they came together what
inspired them to do it and you know we
may have a partnership or something
going on that we'll talk about a little
later and uh just just make sure you
stay tuned because it's all good stuff
it's all good stuff so hanif and Kay are
you there are you with us
yes yes thank you for having us no thank
you for coming on like I was super
excited when we first talked about it I
was like we got to get you on black
voices and gaming because
I I've never heard of a blurred box for
black nerds like I think that's super
incredible that's dope and I supp well I
used to subscribe to a couple of boxes
but now I'm definitely just gonna
exclusively subscribe to the black yeah
yeah but anyways tell us about a taco
Noir tell us how you got started like
what was the inspiration behind it we
want to know all the details
uh the inspiration is actually K she
she's the the inspiration
um I do I guess I'll tell a story
because then Kate can tell me how how
wrong I am in it
this is we created it um she came up
with the idea during the pandemic you
know as you know during the Great Panini
in the sky we couldn't go to any
um Comic-Con events those were suspended
or uh closed down indefinitely so we
missed seeing our local black creators
seeing what independent books they were
doing
um buying their artwork and so okay just
one time one day she just tweeted me
said you know what I wish we had a
service there we can just buy we can
just subscribe to Black uh creators
content just have us tip to our house
and I literally like got out of bed no
light just got out of bed and went on to
the computer looked it up no I didn't
see anyone doing this so let's let's do
this this sounds like a great idea I
don't know why we never thought of it
and we just started rolling with it we
made uh set up a business where we do
quarterly boxes and each box has a
different theme and usually each box is
going to come with a t-shirt uh
Collectibles uh books artwork all from
different uh creators of color
um it's it's something I'm glad actually
it's something I wish we we had created
years ago
I mean but there's no time like the
present right and and now you guys have
got it going and it's super dope because
listen like there are so many black
creators out there like one of the
reasons why black voices in gaming is
what it is because there's so many game
developers out there that nobody sees
right so you doing something like that
for the community like I'm I'm inspired
like I just think that's really really
cool I know I've said that like 32 times
already but I really do like
taking things for the community and
using it in a way to bring us together
even when we couldn't physically be
together like that's something like okay
you woke up that morning you were like I
came to get stuff started and you you
did this is it like and now you're here
you're talking about the box and I know
you were talking about saying each box
has a different theme and I know that
there's a special theme that's going to
be going on with this box so could you
would you show us the box that you guys
have put together and tell us a little
bit about the theme
this is the current theme uh this was
our this is going to be shipped out uh
this month this June uh since we're
quarterly so this is the June box and we
work with uh blurred official uh it's
going to have uh you know exclusive
limited edition t-shirt that you can't
get even on their website gonna have a
lot of different items that are uh that
are from blurred.com as well as our
artwork as and I I don't want to spoil
it but we do have uh some autographed uh
books inside here too from some creators
of color as well so I know people are
going to be really excited and one thing
we want to let people know that each box
is like a mini Comic-Con experience you
know get in the lanyard you get in the
badges you're getting the stickers
you're getting all the other kind of
Swag you're knowing would pick up when
you go to a com uh common good
convention
that's what's up okay okay we haven't
heard from you and I want to hear from
you so yes
you gotta talk okay you gotta talk so
that's the whole point of a silent
partner
you come on to an interview you can't be
so technically let me just say just like
with the idea of the of the box I did
not initially meant for us to create the
box I was just saying I wish there was a
service like that someone took my idea
and was like why don't we do it I was
like no no like I was hesitant I was
like I didn't mean us like I'm not that
kind of person I don't know how to do
any of these things
so I get I get ropes into stuff I have
an idea and someone
him decides you know what that's a
really good idea
the lessons like not telling anybody
else your cool ideas if you don't want
to get roped in but it's too late baby
you're here you know what I mean it is
and I'm glad I'm I am glad that he ran
with this idea because I've been loving
seeing everybody's reaction like I'm a
lurker like I like so I will search
videos of people responding and like how
they how they enjoy the box so like
that's why I don't like being in front
of the camera because I'm like then I
can't like lurk and like I go to cons
and I see people and I'm like oh this is
cool and they just don't know who I am
I'm like that's great they know who he
is they don't need to know me they know
him they know the face it's a brilliant
thing for me I need to drink it to you
but everybody's gonna know who you are
now because in gaming but listen I'm
really quick
that you are on here because there are
so many spaces that are just full of men
that it's really nice to see a woman in
this space regardless if like you don't
want to be on it like after this I
promise we won't bring you back if you
don't want to come back but if you want
to come back we'll bring you back but
it's it's so important to see people who
look like you like that that's part of
the reason why we do this show that's
part of the reason why I put together
games for games is because
representation matters and there's some
little girl out there who loves to
cosplay who loves going to conventions
and she's going to watch this and she's
going to be like oh my God maybe I can
do that someday so whether you know it
or not you are making changes okay
there's somebody out there just like you
who's like man I just want alert but
they're gonna see that like you were
able to get up in front of this camera
and talk about this and like that's
really inspiring okay I just want you to
know that you may not think it is but
that's super inspiring
oh thank you yeah it's it's the lurk for
me I'm just I can't it's hard to pull it
from being a lurker I'm sorry it's
really I understand I'm a bit of an
introvert too it doesn't seem like it
because I'm in front of the camera and I
have to like play it up for the camera
you know but um yeah I I like to learn
too I work on Twitter a lot so no
worries but um okay tell us tell us how
how did you and beneath me because I
feel I feel it feels like a brother or
sisterly Vibe like you definitely give
him his shots and he's like dang like
she came in swinging y'all so tell us a
little bit about that so I'm friends
with his wife
okay we've met me and his wife met in
like 2004 and then she married him and I
was like really do you have to I do
asking a friend
I feel that
I didn't like my friend's husband so see
you're doing better than I am it is like
losing a limb y'all I don't know I can't
seem really cool I would like YouTube
thank you thank you I'm the plus one
that's pretty much what it is I married
into this as long as you know where you
stand you know what I'm saying
and my wife as Kay says she has she has
ideas my wife is
creative director a lot of times she
just comes in this oh why don't you guys
do this and then she Saddles off with
these like what was this these are great
ideas we should go we should run with
that so yeah yeah Teamwork Makes the
Dream Work Derek did you
questions that you wanted to ask because
I know when I first approached you about
it you were like yeah we have to have
them on the show
Oh Derek you're muted
yeah I I mute for as a contingency I
have a baby in the background who might
you know scream it's it's it's a
background thing also dogs and stuff
like that so you know okay anyways the
point being uh does this does this uh
accurate in saying that when uh when she
approached about uh the the Blurred box
of takam Noir I was absolutely excited
uh without a hesitation I was like yes
please sign me up because this dog's I
mentioned earlier but my my question is
my question uh goes back to the strategy
you mentioned it uh kind of being born
out of the pandemic and I think
um that ended up being really excellent
time you you identified a need and then
went to go confirm if that need had
already existed somewhere and then
decided to fill that space up so
um you know it out came from that a new
strategy and I'm curious uh what are
your plans currently and and how are you
can keeping the momentum flowing what
are your current strategies for
otaku Noir
uh I think what we can do now that
everyone can go back out no mask or mask
us or whatever and do conventions it
doesn't stop us from doing what we're
doing because not everyone can make it
to San Diego Comic-Con anime NYC
momocono or HBCU Burke I mean there's
hundreds of conventions unfortunately
not hundreds of black owned conventions
but there's still hundreds if not
thousands of black creators writers
artists musicians game developers we
want this to box to be an opportunity
for them to expand their reach expand
Their audience who want to be uh a
Herald for them you know find out about
bvig you know find out about D for G I
never heard of it what's that it's in
the Box no open up the box you have the
information uh you can go to the website
to learn more to support them directly
you don't have to continue to go through
otaku Noir to find out about this new
writer that I heard about I just I never
knew about this manga before I got this
box and now you're a fan of them that's
what that's what we like K says we love
seeing unboxings we love getting the DMS
from people who enjoy the stuff or you
know telling us oh I had to open up the
box before my kids came home because
last box they took the t-shirt and I
didn't get anything I mean we get so
it's nice to know that our idea is
bringing some happiness to people like
that but uh going forward I think we
each box is kind of like Reinventing
ourselves what new theme had we not done
um because when you create your own
company as you know you can do what you
want but there's so many things out
there so much wonderful content out
there that we can only put so much in
one box per quarter
it's almost like we can come up with
ideas like I said we've collaborated
with blurred uh to produce produce this
box uh we did a fan a black fantasy box
last year called blur to the Rings where
we created our own world had our own
coins Maps uh deck of cards that had
like black uh mermaids black royalty and
stuff like that
um you know we did One exclusive about
villains I mean there's so much stuff
that we can do
um I mean we have another box coming out
in September that I know you guys are
gonna that uh will tell your audience
about in a little bit but there's so
much that we can do that I think
um
looking at our company is similar to you
know going down the bread isle at the
supermarket where you don't just have
one type of bread now you can have
hundreds if not thousands of different
types of bread whole wheat white bread
whatever that's what our box like we
have something for everybody
and that's what's up
I know one of the things that I saw that
you were promoting
um
Vampire in Brooklyn and it was a cereal
box and that was oh my God I
I've never seen it
do you have the vampire and Brooklyn
cereal box because listening
that should have been a real cereal
right there okay we're not culinary food
poisoning is like that that's what we
draw the line we can give you ideas no
we can put confetti in it but you know
you're like nobody's getting any Cocoa
Puffs like it's incredible yeah
we come up with our own custom mazes you
know we're in like the uh what's good
the word jumble and stuff uh even got
the fake ingredients
so
yo that gatekeeping one that's on point
at some point because it's about
Community it's about teamwork right and
like I love some of the things that you
were saying earlier like it's not just
about like what we can put in the box
it's about like putting things in the
box that gets other people known for
what they're doing and you don't have to
keep subscribing to us but like if you
find something you like and you keep
subscribing to like getting those Comics
or like getting that art like that's
helping somebody else in the community
and and I love that so we are running
short on time but before we do I just
want to quickly talk about the box that
we are partnering with you so games for
games and black voices and gaming are
partnering with the taco Noir to bring
you guys the most incredible blurred box
experience ever and I think we have a
box that we could show them what it
looks like like it looks so so dope guys
like it's incredible
[Music]
how good it's going to look in in the in
the shot it's gonna look even better in
person y'all I'm hyping it up I'm hyping
it up that's clean
hey
and I'll show you everyone inside for
the life hacks for all those you know
the gamers of our age you know got a
little salt and pepper in there and they
remember some of these codes and whatnot
like I said the life hacks there you
know the Konami Code
yeah
well we got the uh
Sonic you know uh let's see if we can
see it on this side you got the other
yeah I'm sure if you can look at it real
quick you know what those life hacks are
without even
doing that so again we're we're blessed
to be able to work with both of your
organizations to provide our audience
with uh
gaming content made by people of color I
mean honestly when you think about video
games you just think of the big
publishing big developers and stuff you
don't think about the independent ones
as well as the people who are behind the
scenes on it and for me personally the
gaming theme it's been something that's
been you know jumping around in my head
for a while now because my son he's in
college and he wants to go get into game
design so I felt not so much that this
box is automatically represent what he
wants to do but it allows me to then dig
a little bit deeper into the behind the
scenes of the gaming industry what is he
potentially going to be doing with his
career uh hopefully uh in the in the
gaming industry well I I have a I have a
comment on that one you need to send
your son our way specifically send them
my way to I teach game design I teach 3D
modeling uh you know black voices and
black voices of the gaming is here to
support what y'all are doing but also
you know we want to support the entry of
new voices as well so don't be a
stranger
um when it comes to this box because I
know there's going to be people in our
audience as well as others that are
ready to receive it for those who are
just hearing about it for the first time
where can we where can we find out where
to subscribe or can we prepare our hands
for the receipt of this upcoming game
box
if you go to otaku noir.com uh just it
might be easy to see it this way there's
a talk with noir.com all one word you
can go online now to purchase the box it
is uh sixty dollars
um but we also have the affirm option I
believe so that we can if you want to
you know break it down into installment
payments but this box doesn't ship until
September so you have until August 28th
to place your order uh as time proceeds
we will let people know a little bit
more of what's going to go in the box we
have a lot of great things in store for
you I guarantee you everyone will be
happy with what's inside these boxes
oh yes oh yes so y'all stay tuned and
and save your pennies and your nickels
and your dimes so you can get this box
because it's perfect bookmark that
webpage definitely yeah yeah well follow
us on Instagram we'll definitely let
everyone know uh more about the box as
you know as the time goes on we'll be
revealing stuff not exactly what's in
the box but more hints so that way you
can know the wet your appetite to let
you know what to expect uh when you get
this box they said they're going to
tease y'all
[Laughter]
thank you so much for coming on and
spending some time with us and telling
us about the Blurred box make sure you
go check them out make sure you follow
them on their social media because
listen they're doing the game box but
like they're gonna keep making boxes and
I definitely know that they'll be
something that you'll see that you'll
love like like I wanted the cereal box
I'm a little sad that there's no cereal
in it but um I want the box and it's
just use it as a cereal box holder for
yourself
Cocoa Pebbles and stick it in there
anyways
imagine could you imagine having like
some chocolate Frosted Flakes and
pulling that out for somebody who did
not know it wasn't a real cereal
that would be great that would be great
but anyway
come to the end of our time and um it's
been great this interview has been so
eye-opening please continue to do what
you guys are doing like it really is
like a I don't know you I say
everybody's inspirational but like okay
you're inspirational girl I know I know
you I know you want alert but I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm say your name every time I
go somewhere and be like yeah have y'all
heard of K she got that
yeah
I
promise she says that when she showed up
on the interview but anyways guys that's
it for us with this interview stay tuned
for more we'll see you soon
thank you
[Music]
foreign
that was the latest trailer from corrupt
we're with the Creator himself Jesse
Wright we've been talking to Jesse for a
long time when we used to host uh mix
events at Evo like you've been to gdt uh
the like the afro-tech Showcase like
you've been going everywhere you had
black salt corruption
um and now you're really getting ready
towards the launch of corrupt how's it
going
man it's been it's been a crazy Journey
so far but you know it's it's been an
exciting kind of Road developing corrupt
and yeah starting with like bikes all
corruption and transitioning into
corrupt and then kind of getting it
where it is now it's been an exciting
process for sure and hey shout out to
you guys for sure like seeing everything
from vegan mix events and stuff a couple
years back and seeing how everything has
progressed now it's like shout out to
you for that it's been really awesome
seeing this platform grow
yeah absolutely
uh you know I think it's been I've had a
chance to check out black salt
corruption that's actually where it my
my knowledge about this game really came
into place and so when I heard uh about
corrupt I was like wait a minute I know
something's changed and so
um I would love to hear about you know
how you came up with the name a little
bit of the background in it and just you
know your relationship to fighting games
yeah so
um kind of going with the so black soul
corruption uh that was kind of a whole
different project altogether where I got
to collaborate with one of my mentors
who owns the black salt franchise and we
just had a random idea one day of you
know what if you know I made a fighting
game they kind of brought some of your
characters and my characters in and you
know just like an arcade experience
something like the Dreamcast days and uh
that's kind of where black salt
corruption
was created then kind of going from
there I think we did yeah just steam
Early Access and then we had started
working on trying to get it on the
switch but then covet it happened and it
was so crazy like getting through lot
check and stuff like that so uh in the
background I had always been working on
corrupt that was like again bike saw
corruption was bringing together his
property in mind and so
um corrupt was that that's been my baby
since I was in like high school I've
been writing about gambling uh so being
able to finally have the opportunity now
uh to to bring this story uh and make a
game around it everything has been like
super awesome
and then going to what I've been with
the fighting game uh community and genre
like I've been competing online in
tournaments for so long and I've been
fortunate to hit some leaderboards and
stuff to where I've made a lot of
friends that are in the fighting game
community and I go to a lot of those
events as well so naturally kind of
wanting to make a fighting game and
playing and consuming a lot of the
fighting games that are out on the
market it's just kind of always been
what I love and wanted to do so
so the game is uh progressed over the
last few years you you work with a few
other Publishers to help you get to you
to where you're at now
um can you tell us about the progress
that you've made up to this point and
kind of where your your uh working on
the the release
for the game yeah so so yeah I've worked
with a couple different Publishers now
uh getting to this point and really what
it's been is you know a fighting game is
such a niche genre where Publishers you
know they get excited about it but then
it's like well we actually sit down and
try to come up with a plan on how we're
going to Market and roll things out
that's what he kind of was like okay you
know we don't know if we're the right
fit for this project so it's never been
any like bad blood or any horrible
situations or anything like that it's
just been more like okay this isn't the
right fit for us but hey we'll help you
you know along the road or whatever and
uh
yeah like the progress I've made so far
is also just being able to build my team
up a lot stronger where before it
started with blueprints that I made and
I am no programmer by any beads or
anything uh so putting together
blueprints in and just having something
functional at one point was super
exciting uh and then some of the people
that I actually met in the unreal forums
that I started working with and started
slowly building a team but then more
recently uh there is a Development Group
that they've been making some different
fan fighting games uh that have done
like a pretty big splash where the
fighting game Community went crazy over
um but we we kind of teamed up and had
talked about working together a lot in
the past and then finally kind of took
that step once I uh started working with
a new publisher and now things have just
been progressing well and we can we can
finally see that light at the end of the
tunnel
um definitely will be content complete
you know now we could see those those
dates and those milestones and things so
as far as the release window
oh no hard release date just yet but we
definitely are moving towards it now
finally
yeah yeah so you you talked about
building your team and I'm curious what
about building your community you know
fighting games have a specific resonance
with the black community I we all play
fighting games here we're looking
forward to fighting games on the on the
way I'm looking forward to corrupt how
do you get your community charged for a
title like this
yeah so you know it's been a while since
I've shown any gameplay or anything on
corrupt because it was kind of at that
point where I noticed I had dropped some
gameplay and would get like a really big
response but then it's like I'm showing
them exactly like what we just got to
that day so I'm like super excited about
it like oh man let me get this out here
and then it goes crazy and then it's
like I don't really have much to show
you know like a couple weeks later so it
was like let me build this up let me
actually uh you know work with some
fighting game community members let them
test the demos out you know different
builds and stuff that we've had and so
that's really been how I've done it it's
just kind of having builds that I I'll
let fighting game players like kind of
get their hands on and do some testing
and you know get different feedback from
them and yeah just kind of working with
them but kind of been quietly doing that
so far but now to try to let people know
that we actually are kind of back on
track with everything it's like getting
these hike trailers out trying to show
people like the different characters
kind of reintroducing the ones they've
seen with the new mechanics and
everything in place and then start
showing all the different characters
they haven't seen and you know hopefully
we'll build it that way and again just
you got to give people access you got to
put the controller in their hand with
the fighting game to really get that
feedback so getting to that as soon as
possible and then kind of going from
there with more trailers
last time I I checked out the game it
felt really good I mean you've been
shooting me over builds every once in a
while when you feel it
right I just uh
want you to tell the audience like we
this is like the new like season of
fighting games coming out we got Tekken
Eight coming out we got Street Fighter
six dropping actually in the you know
right now so yeah yeah it looks like
today tomorrow right
so can you explain like how it
differentiates itself like from other
fighters in a genre so people could kind
of know what they're kind of getting
into
yeah so
corrupt is a 1v1 hyperfighter so it has
like things like super jumps you know
air combos air juggling and different
things like that you know there's a lot
of really uh there's a lot of defensive
mechanics but because the characters all
have like these crazy move sets so every
character feels like dramatically broken
but because there's so much uh defensive
options and things like that you're able
to like no one's more broken than the
other right so it's just been kind of
exciting building from that and you know
seeing all the new fighting games that
are coming out it's been super hype
because now people are talking about
fighting games you know so it's going to
get a lot of people actually trying
different stuff out and when they're
like you know they jump into a legacy
title like a street fighter or a Mortal
Kombat and realize what Legacy is right
they jump online you know they might
still have that taste for a fighting
game and that's where corrupt will be
there you know so
I think
um
yeah that's that's really the biggest
thing that'll differentiate though is
just that that fast-paced hyper fighter
word word is there do you have a
favorite character
uh I don't know if I should say that
right like
all of them are my favorite right right
right but but definitely I would say uh
I find myself
trying out the character named destroy
the one with the mask uh I kind of
leaned a lot on that character I like
his I like his uh okay
I I have a brief follow-up and I want to
toss it back to you Justin if if there's
not a favorite character I would love to
know what influenced you know some of
the art direction for the game
so that was definitely from just people
in my life
um you know like Gatling was actually
kind of modeled after how I envisioned
my brother growing up you know I'm the
little brother so just I put a lot of
those qualities and stuff into Gatling
uh and then like with uh the character
Beretta that was based off one of my
sisters and you know so I put a lot of
that kind of in the characters and
yeah just based off people I know in
like real life experiences
that's love
I think that's kind of a common theme
around the the developers that we've
been speaking with today they put a lot
of personal influence and their culture
and life into the to the characters that
they're creating in the worlds they're
building can you talk a little bit about
because you were you kind of bruised
briefly described how you started making
these characters when you're very young
how that process has been evolving them
from being you know what I mean being a
youngster not being in the game industry
and then build characters out how is
that a progression then yeah it's been
really crazy you know seeing like I
can't really draw that well but going
from the sketches that I first had of
the characters and like the different
artists that I've worked with getting to
now uh it's definitely been crazy
working with like a bunch of different
illustrators and character uh character
designers that would bring a lot of like
okay they're like okay read what you
have about him and I see this design you
know what if we do this and you know
just being open to to making sure the
characters it's like I had this vision
for corrupting these characters
basically as being something like I love
the Final Fantasy and the tales of and
like jrpg genre and it was really like
man you know it'll be dope to have a
black lead character in a final fantasy
type game and so that's kind of where
the Direction came from with a lot of
the characters is uh I kind of want this
Final Fantasy futuristic type aesthetic
you know but uh having more diverse
characters in it just more
representative of you know what my life
looks like so
yeah it's uh it's been crazy seeing it
evolve now and seeing Gatling kind of
look like a real person and it's just
like yeah coming from Little sketches in
high school which of now has been pretty
crazy
yeah yeah
that that journey is uh without a doubt
inspiring many other you know uh people
in the fighting game Community up and
coming individuals who maybe are seeking
an entry into games and so you know I'm
really appreciative of you being able to
share that story and just the Arc of you
know where it started to to where it is
now
um I I would if I can squeeze in with
the time that we have left I would love
to know what's on the horizon for
corrupt uh you know this year next year
and and where can people look forward to
catching up to those updates
so uh we will uh definitely be dropping
more character reveals as we go on
throughout the summer uh we'll
definitely have a lot of info dropping
at and around Evo this year
so uh I don't know the exact dates off
the top of my head but definitely tune
in to Evo if you're excited about uh
what's going on with corrupt and like I
said we're just gonna do some character
reveals then we're going to start
showing the different modes within
corrupt and then we have to show you why
it's called corrupt that's one thing I
haven't done yet is why is it misspelled
corrupt that way you know that's
something that we're actually going to
reveal uh a little bit later on here and
kind of ramp up to that so yeah just
more introduction characters in the
world the gameplay what to expect and
then eventually we'll get to that that
uh launch trailer and
yeah hopefully it's it's not too too far
but you know won't say anything right
now
I was about to ask you about the
misspelling that's one thing I think
over the years I've never ever asked you
that was like
you did that on purpose right oh yeah a
lot of people a lot of people bring that
up like oh you know it's misspelled and
I'm like I thought about it I'm aware
you know so yeah you like getting mad at
me and I like spell it right you know
right
that's hilarious well uh where can we
find you on social media and everything
because we want to make sure that folks
can follow you and check out the game
yeah definitely right now you can check
out uh me on Twitter at uh JW underscore
correlated it misspelled like how
corrupt is and uh that'll be probably
the best spot right now uh but working
on revamping our website and everything
and we also will be dropping a comic uh
this summer as well the first issue of
it so
definitely wish list the game cop it
when it comes out check out Evo uh
thanks so much Jesse it's awesome to see
your your progress on everything man
that you don't quit I think that's one
of the most awesome Parts about your
your hustling to see people in the space
it's like I think we're all like-minded
in this circle so it's dope I'm sure
it'll really open for you
thank you and yeah it's uh you know
can't give up this is this is the the
kind of industry the world we love you
know so it's like I would make this
corrupt game happen no matter what man
thanks man thank you
that was so dope now we're back at it
the Triforce is back it was like two off
everything
it was like two offs every time we never
got to interview you know what I mean I
know
next time for sure I mean what was some
of your favorite stuff that you uh were
able to communicate with the devs about
the black woman and being in that place
and starting a studio was really really
cool and I think like her talking about
like being in rooms and seeing like
where you might be one like the only
person there just one of two was really
important because I think that's what
I'm experiencing in the game industry
where it's just me and I'm looking for
other people who look like me and who
have like worked that hard so that was
really cool but then again all of our
guests were really really dope like they
all brought something incredible to the
Showcase as they always do uh past
guests as well Derek what did you think
who what was your favorite moment
uh it's hard to have a favorite moment I
I always enjoy getting to celebrate like
the diversity in both games and content
that gets brought to the show and so you
know there's something special about
everybody who had something to talk
about
um I really enjoyed getting to check out
Breeze in the clouds really enjoyed
getting to chat with Jesse about a
corrupt and uh is seeing where games are
intersecting in different mediums and
speaking of different mediums you know
the Elko Taco Noir box you know was was
also yeah with them yeah
that was really cool and
Justin just so you know like you should
you should tell everybody everybody
needs to go and try to win one of these
gaming boxes because we're gonna have
some merch in it right like which is in
gaming is putting some merch in this box
games for games is putting some merch in
the Box you don't want to miss out on us
you really don't because yeah
there's gonna be some dope dope stuff
coming through yeah I'll tell you mine
I'm I'm mad biased though I'm not gonna
be playing
in this piece come on right now
I really like here that you're right all
of them were dope I really liked
um Indigo because I remember when I was
a younger developer and then she's got
that energy to to really bring herself
and her life to to the um to her game
um and you don't always you didn't you
don't always often see that and that's
what it's about when you're going Indy
you know uh also Danielle she's
you know she's working on hyper light
breaker and I was about to like mess up
the name but hyper light breaker breaker
at heart machine games and just her
experience and then the studio being so
cool to allow her to have her creative
freedom and and express herself in the
game was pretty pretty excellent so it's
it's awesome to see ourselves in in
these these places
um in these spaces and I I can't wait to
hear more about what people are are
doing you know
um so that's it we're gonna be closing
off the show I'm always so amazed at the
talent of course hard work that we get
to Showcase here at bvig
um and we got sponsors who are who have
been amazing who've been working with us
um over the years PlayStation ID at Xbox
again raw Fury Razer Wilson sancini
who's supporting
um our developers with legal help
anywhere from incorporate to IP law
publishing contracts and more
so great
that's right I don't want to give thanks
I'll take it I'll take it
thank you for the Baton uh thanks to the
mix team in a medium one media one of
course they've continued to break
barriers and build a foundation for
Indie developers and it's been an
amazing journey to watch thanks to our
broadcasting Partners it goes to Twitch
IGN Steam and Gamespot and of course
don't forget about that steam event page
the mix the mix event page on Steam is
where you can learn more about the vvig
titles by the available games or add
them to your wish list wish lists are
really important let me tell you they
help developers a ton so be sure you add
the ones that you like or you know add
them all because again add all of them
put them all in there buy them
buy them
demos while we're talking about buying
and adding and all that stuff don't
forget to donate guys like grab your
phone snap that QR code no amount is too
small and we truly appreciate it it
really goes a long way it helps us to
continue this wonderful showcase show
you awesome content and help the
developers who are creating and making
their dreams come true also the merch I
I mean I can't say enough about the
merch we are going to be expanding it we
got t-shirts I mean we don't have hats
we're gonna do we don't do everything so
make sure you're checking out the merch
and don't forget to follow us on our
socials all right that's black voices
and gaming on Instagram
BVI gaming on Twitter and black voices
of gaming on YouTube guys check it out
go to our website as well if you want to
find out what we're doing next that's
blackvoicesgaming.org now before I end
we also have to give a shout out to
Netflix again because yeah what they're
doing with us this partnership is
incredible and we are so honored to be
partnering with them on our first
accelerator program called The
Experience excellent accelerator guys
I'm gonna say that one more time
experience Excellence accelerator where
we will be helping to fund for black
developed mobile game prototypes the
accelerator will include workshops and
curriculum from professional mentors and
networking opportunities with the goal
of helping to boost professional
developers progress on their games and
get them ready for further investment or
publishing opportunity if you're
interested in being a part of the
experience Excellence bvig Netflix
mobile game accelerated program please
submit your application and go to the
website for more details remember that's
experience with an XP not exp XP
guys this this has been absolutely
incredible as always I love rocking the
entire bvig team this showcase continues
to grow and get better we're constantly
looking for ways to uplift the black
creators in the game Space like I've
always said and will continue to say you
deserve to be seen heard and respected
we're building a foundation for future
Generations we appreciate all the
encouragement from the gaming industry
and will maintain our focus of making
the community we love more inclusive and
better for everyone involved
if you want to find out more about me be
sure to check me out on Twitter at
dnbc32 or now you can check out games
for games on Twitter as well where I
will be giving you tons of information
about upcoming shows where we'll be
constantly highlighting women and their
contributions to the gaming community
and Industry
on the Baton today to Derek
that was a confusing
you know out
thank you again everybody for joining
another great show uh you know what
we're about here and that's supporting
the developers I can't say enough to to
be able to check out those steam Pages
check out those games and show your
support as well if you want to continue
to see content like this consider
donating I love bringing this content
and hosting these developers with the
likes of Justin and Dez but if you want
to know more about me feel free to drop
me a follow on at Twitter or whatever
you prefer that's Derek V Fields uh
Justin what do you got to say before we
before we go baton
just because one last time
but we'll ask the time pass
you can follow black voice and gaming at
BVI gaming for sure you could uh find me
at icj man everywhere else I hope you
all enjoyed yourself uh thanks for
rocking with us thanks to devs all our
sponsors we had a blast introducing you
to some new games developers and the
people making moves in the industry by
doing their own dang I'm your host
Justin Woodward see you soon
peace
[Music]